let's take some phone calls our phone
number 617 830 for 750 is the number any
questions any comments any critiques
always love to hear from you 617 830 for
750 is the number let's start with your
name and where you're calling from Oh
Joey arm from shandola PA alright Joe
what can we do for you um David I was
just wondering if if the rapture does
happen if you believe it or not yeah
would you get the mark of the beast that
we know out of it uh I don't know what
you're asking me you're saying would I
take the mark of the beast yeah like arm
here like stories and our movies arm
yeah dragon you like you'll you die or
take the mark of the beast and you know
what that means you absolutely will go
tell if you take it now Isaac it wasn't
when you telling me Rachel you have a
tattoo that is considered the mark of
the beast right I do ya know i i'd
honestly I don't know what you're
talking about i would probably not take
the mark of the beast if the rapture
happened i don't know am I allowed to
take it being Jewish um well I mean you
know about the rapture and stuff ready
oh yeah believe me I've interviewed a
number of people who by all accounts
should have been raptured by now oh
that's uh okay um is this for real is
this little [ __ ] hall I'm just not
sure about that oh I'm I'm boring gang
Kristen you're completely for real no no
how would i say i asked always in love
I'm always I'm always curious and I
sometimes um writes up and on your face
I mean I facebook um your YouTube
channel right I always want because you
don't really believe now in that's right
sir yeah who are you voting for I'm
actually not voting for anyone this year
I'm 31 y on it is being 31 related to
why you're
not voting now i just want like now how
old I am okay but why are you writing
I'm curious I'm actually very good i'm
getting sucked into this why aren't you
voting day i'm i'm gonna dig a little
deeper here waiting a little bit i
register for a while so you just not
registered there's no big sociological
or political reason you just aren't
registered to vote yet not for a long
time not since the second arm if you
were registered who would you vote for
I'd answer his question on the last time
I voted was when arm bush his second
term I voted for him hey but listen rat
last thing Rachel did ask a good
question which is if you were to vote
who would you vote for in this election
on Donald Trump okay all right very good
we'll listen you've said it all truly uh
I thank you for the call from shenandoah
Pennsylvania and I wish you the best of
luck and and everything else right i
mean i don't think i can say anything
thank you we do have to move on though
Shenandoah Pennsylvania checking in Joey
there thank you swore be Parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / tdps I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold war be par
distributes a pair of glasses to someone
in need you can try five pairs and see
what you like check out the at home
trial and support our show by going to
warby parker dot-com / TDPS it costs
nothing